mais regrettez-vous à l'absence d'un
interdit claire de relations sexuelles
entre un majeur et un mineur de moins de
15 ans oui parce que c'était les
attendus un peu et qui a été annoncé par
le gouvernement et ça a été vécue si
c'est autour de cet article 2 que les
choses ont été des monts ont conduit à
des débats un peu difficile et un peu
houleux c'est que nous estimions
conformément à ce qu'avait dit marlène
schiappa escale du gouvernement qu'il
fallait inverser la charge de la preuve
d'une certaine façon et dire par nature
un acte sexuel en dessous de 15 ans on
parle pas du viol parce que la question
du viol elle reste dans la loi il n'y a
pas de recul du tout là dessus puisque
même l'imprescriptibilité et augmenter
la prescriptive ilité pardon est
augmentée en revanche il nous semblait
que d'inverser les choses permettait que
ça soit pas à l'enfant de montrer qu'il
était consentant ou pas qu'on s'entend
parce que c'est évidemment un élément
qui est très sensible et très important
pour nous ceci étant la glisse est quand
même dans cet article de quelque chose
qui est de dire dans le consentement
tient compte de la vulnérabilité de
l'enfant qui est une avancée c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que ce point-là plus les
autres ont justifié le vote favorable
ces débats curité très passionné voire
passionnel ces débats très sensible
toujours après il faut toujours à la
fois tenir cette passion parce que c'est
bien que les gens portent les choses
avec ce qui est leur connaissance du
sujet leurs appréhensions de tel ou tel
point d'un texte et en même temps il
faut le faire avec la raison le
gouvernement nous a opposé la question
de la constitutionnalité peut-être cet
inversement de la charge dix ans on fait
on passe de la présomption d'innocence à
la présomption de culpabilité at-il
fallait-il risque est justement cet
incident finalité parfois osées utile de
doses et de risquer leur pas toute fin
parce que parfois on fait des lois en
sachant qu'on va au bout au contentieux
constitutionnel et que le conseil
constitutionnel a retoqué alors on fait
reporter la charge de cette décision
dont on savait par avance qu'elle ne
passerait pas au conseil constitutionnel
ce qui est intellectuellement est un peu
malhonnête mais là peut-être qu'il
fallait pousser c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est exprimé assez fortement sur
l'article 2 on pensait qu'on pouvait
aller plus loin que le texte qui nous
était présentée est à la hauteur de ce
qui avait été espéré ce qui est dommage
c'est que c'est un texte qui était au
démarrage qui aurait dû trouver les
voies d'un consensus
on l'a vu hier sur notre niche on l'a
trouvé un consensus sur trois des quatre
textes que nous proposions
là on a on a manqué à ce consensus c'est
un peu dommage comment comment vous
l'expliquez est-ce que c'est marlène
scapa qui a braqué le débat comme le
disait olivier faur non non enfin je
crois que tout le monde s'est braqué
dans ce débat mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse les uns et les autres
attention à nos attitudes je pense que
la journée de mardi était une journée un
peu épidermique et les basses et braquer
tout le monde s'est braqué et la journée
de mercredi a été plus comment dire est
plus apaisée je pense que le ton d'un
débat
on peut avoir des positions radicalement
différente la façon dont on dit les
choses
c'est important parce que d'abord on
doit ça au débat démocratique et en plus
ça permet d'avancer de faire la loi
pas sous le coup de la colère avait de
l'émotion mais sous le coup de la raison
et du ski et le droit au sortir de ce
débat est ce que finalement le
l'interdît est renforcée oui parce que
la présomption du domaine nabéré
vulnérabilité de l'enfant est quand même
un élément important pour le juge que le
juge pourra dire peut-être qu'il était
consentant mais je pense qu'il était
vulnérable et c'est un faux débat sont
lancés les associations sur ce sujet oui
c'est un vrai débat c'est un vrai débat
parce qu'on a eu des affaires on est
d'où est partie ce texte alors ça nous a
d'ailleurs nous incite à la prudence
l'origine des textes il est parti d'une
affaire qui est arrivé dans le val
d'oise et qui avait beaucoup sensibilisé
en particulier le député chez nous
nathalie et limaces et patrick mignola
aussi lui-même
c'est un débat qui montre cet enfant là
on a considéré qu'il n'y avait pas ni
d'atteinte sexuelle n'était pas une
question de vue il n'y avait pas
d'atteinte sexuelle parce que finalement
elle était peut-être consentante
simplement il ya un âge on peut estimer
que quelles que soient les choses qui se
passent
on estime que c'est pas qu'on s'entend
donc je pense que c'est un débat et on y
reviendra probablement parce que c'est
une évolution de la société et des tas
de pays européens qui ont été un peu
plus loin que ce qu'on a fait dans ce
texte
ceci dit à des avancées moi je considère
qu'il ya des avancées
si nous votions contre la prescriptive
il était resté à 20 ans si nous votions
contre la vulnérabilité n'étaient pas
prises en compte si nous votions contre
l'outragé que sexiste dans la rue elles
n'étaient pas prises en compte onze
il faut être rationnel dans la vie et
donc c'est pour ça que il semble que
c'est une avancée même si c'est pour
beaucoup pour un certain nombre un peu
décevant effectivement